hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest
uh rhonda oh my gosh hallman coleman
oh yeah like whole pan get it like two
words mixed
sorry um and today we are actually going
to talk about airway
health i know this is a little bit
different of a topic than we normally do
on the channel but as you guys know on
this channel we are focused
on improving all aspects of our lives
whether that's mental physical
um or anything like that so that is why
i brought rhonda on
because she actually her channel made me
realize that a lot of my health problems
were connected
for something that i didn't ever like
think about like something that i never
like
thought could be a problem um so i
wanted you
to maybe put in your own words tell them
what you do
for a living and what your channel is
about absolutely thank you so much for
having me this is
this is awesome like this is everything
i ever wanted like not to just reach
people in my career field but like to
find the public and tell them hey look
at this
but i am a 21-year dental assistant
so i've been looking at airway disorders
for two
decades and uh it was about three or
four years ago i really dove into like
how mouth breathing
is affecting like our overall well-being
and um if you're in the dental
profession you have a chance to look at
the signs and the symptoms before the
comorbidities truly like set in
and i spent you know so many years
writing down like these different things
like
flat teeth on the front gum receding
um scalloped tongue like all these
things i would write down in my notes
and i'm like gosh
like i'm clinically supposed to note
these differences
and i see it in all these different
people but
i never could tell the patient well this
is why and now i can so
it's been like a career passion of mine
to figure out the root cause
and i i finally got there and i'm really
close uh putting it all together to help
other people see it
wait so did you did you initially start
searching like for yourself
or was it for your patients oh yeah yeah
and i think
that's a really cool point is like my
favorite type
of provider whether it's mental health
you know even for a car like you
have the same kind of car i have and you
figured out how to change that
transmission
to where it runs better like i'm gonna
go to that guy because you have a buick
27
15 model or whatever you know um and so
yes
i was an airway disorder person myself
and i went to a ce course and it was
like a whole day where they were telling
us about
mandibular advancement devices so
basically a
huge part of the population that has a
breathing disorder right and it really
hits them hard at night when they're
sleeping and it's obstructive sleep
apnea
okay well they wear these hoses on their
nose and it pushes air down
you know so that they don't struggle to
breathe while they sleep and
this course was about this appliance
that dentistry can provide patients that
don't want the hose
and it brings your jaw forward which
brings your tongue forward which makes
your air hole bigger
so you're less likely to suffocate while
you sleep
but the entire day all they talked about
was plastic
whether they were talking about the cpap
or they were talking about the oral
appliance nobody talked about why it
happened
and and i just started connecting dots
and then i was like oh this is why i'm
grinding my teeth
oh so you grinded your teeth oh yes
every night
oh yeah so what like symptoms did you
have that like started you on this
journey so you had teeth grinding you
mentioned
like what else was there oh yeah well
you know the
the most of us this starts in childhood
like
literally they're tracing it back to
before we were even born
you know like some of these vaulted
pallets like the roof of your mouth
being really narrow
um but you know as a kid man i had ear
infections throat infections i peed the
bed
well past the age of three i had like in
sores on my lip um i had cavities
a baby kit you know like my baby teeth
had cavities i
had um you know just migraines which was
really weird for like
a kid to have migraines and learning
curve issues like i was i was struggling
to stay awake in school so i was super
hyperactive like just trying to stay
awake and then my
grades i never had a passion for
learning because i didn't want to sit
still because i was afraid
and uh and it's funny because like all
these things like they added up and then
all my crooked teeth and they had to
take out
let's see i am missing eight teeth
they took out eight teeth because my
face did not fit my teeth
because i was breathing through my mouth
which leads to
under development of the face so and
that's one thing i think the public
really needs to know
is the teeth just show you where the
bone is if there's not enough room for
teeth
then there's not enough bone why is
there not enough bone
where is your tongue like your tongue is
what grows
and if your tongue is up it grows your
face and pushes on the bone
and could you say that one more time
like that
so the teeth you just show you where the
bone is
so if your teeth are crooked you have an
underdeveloped face
and then you have to figure out is there
a chance i'm mouth breathing is there a
chance my tongue isn't holding up the
roof of my mouth making my face grow
well it's interesting because you
actually put on your social media you
like grew your face like your chin is
like further forward your nose starts to
turn
yeah like look at that side wait show it
again show it again look her side
profile is literally perfect people
pay for that and like it's like
like i was so sorry i was thinking about
this earlier like
you know a lot of us have all of these
imperfections right we have
all of these um things that a lot of us
are insecure about
and i truly believe that it's just our
body trying to tell us something's up
like i was insecure about the size of my
nose i thought dude if i was ever
getting plastic surgery it'd be on my
nose because it's too fat
i didn't like it and it's because it was
underused like there's muscles in here
that they were just fatigued right
and they were swollen and you know my
face
like all of these things like even the
the space between my boobs
it was crazy right i was always super
insecure when i was like in a bathing
suit because i'm like dude my boobs are
so far apart
but it was because of my upper chest
breathing because i was breathing with
my mouth
and so my entire rib cage was just
stretched out
and i could get my boobs to come
together what dude
i'm telling you there's so many things
we can change
and and the fact that that you know most
of us wait till we're super sick but
it's it's fascinating well it's
interesting because
um i actually i have a dv i had a
deviated septum so when i was 22
i went to the allergy doctor because i
like i couldn't breathe right so i went
to the allergy doctor
and they one found out i was allergic to
like everything
and the second thing they told me
they're like you you i like can't see up
half your nose
and i went to the doctor and they told
me i had a 90 blockage
in half my nose so i couldn't even
breathe and
um i ended up like getting surgery and
getting it fixed
and i found it like you don't even have
to do that right you can just like
you can totally bio-hack your way
through that like that's what people
don't get like you don't have to go
under the knife you guys like it's about
function and behavior
like you can override half of the
anatomical issues like some
dude you just can't but think about why
you got a deviated septum in the first
place
if you weren't mouth breathing and your
tongue was sucked up to the roof of your
mouth
it's scaffolding for the bottom of your
nose so if your tongue had been up there
while you were growing dude your nose
the deviation wouldn't happened
yeah and that's what like i actually
ended up getting like a little bit taken
off of my nose like because i had a bump
and they just
i just was going under anyway i was like
take it off and i'm starting to realize
like i think there were more
repercussions from that than i realized
at the time you know what i mean
yeah well there's this one thing called
empty nose syndrome
and and that's kind of why i kind of
jumped on understanding buteyko
breathing which we can get into later
but
what happens is they take out too much
stuff
and um they feel like they're drowning
with air it's crazy like
there's this whole population of people
that are suffering from that because
like you know they thought that that
would fix things but they didn't fix the
function first i'm like do i have i
don't think so
i don't know okay so
what um what is your advice
to people that are just like starting on
their airway journey
like i'm not talking going like you're
kind of the extreme
right like she like lays on the ground
and then breathes
um what is it yeah advice for people
that are just starting
well where i started you know honestly
like
my grinding of my teeth i was like
there's got to be a better way
literally the first thing i ever did
even before i started slowing down my
breath with breath work
and changing the food you know so my gut
health would help me breathe better
i just tape my lips and i know not
everybody can do that especially if
you've already been
diagnosed with obstructive sleep apnea
so
obstructive sleep apnea is when body
parts are literally cutting off your air
supply
okay but there's a lot of us with uars
which is upper airway resistance so it's
just
it takes a lot of effort to breathe
while we're sleeping because everything
goes to sleep when we do especially when
hit rim
everything but your diaphragm and your
heart like paralyzed
and so if your body parts are floppy and
not
toned and you're not doing anything
extra to make your airway bigger while
you sleep
you just you have to put in a whole lot
of effort and then you come out of rim
and you never get restorative sleep
where you heal
and so it's understanding the connection
between the way you breathe during the
day will dictate how you breathe at
night
so honestly taping my lips changed my
life it was like one week
my hip pain was gone my grinding was
gone my migraines went away like i was
like what the hell
is happening like what did i stumble
into
well that's what i just started doing um
so if you guys don't know i actually
think i have
a piece of lip tape next to me it's like
you just take these very small like
pieces
um and it's actually not even that
uncomfortable like i was expecting it to
be way worse
and you just put it on your like lips at
night and you sleep like a million times
better
yeah you don't get a pee i mean some
people like i first when i first did it
because i hadn't done the breath work i
was snoring through my nose and my
husband hit me and i'm like
i was like i can't where i'm taping my
lips um but
yeah so you can still snore with your
lips taped um
and that's when you kind of like run
into that next phase of like
figuring stuff out is like how do i slow
down my breath so i don't create enough
suction and velocity to pull my body
parts in
wait um so your phase one would be
the lip tape and then phase two you
would say would you say the eating would
be phase two or would you say it would
be more like working on the breath work
i think the breath work um is super
important because you have to understand
when you stop breathing through your
mouth you feel like you're suffocating
because you're so used to getting so
much more air from your mouth
um even though it's not quality air and
it doesn't do as much for your body
you just you feel like you're
suffocating so like there's no way i
would have stuck with
lip taping if i felt like i was
suffocating every night if i didn't do
the breath work because the breath work
does a couple things it helps get the
snot out of your nose
and it helps you get used to less breath
you know it's just if the breath work
wasn't there i don't know that i was
stuck it out with tape
because everything's like what do you
mean when you say it's not
quality air because um a lot of people
are like new to this sort of thing
i know well so what happens all right
there's a couple components
i won't get into the science of it too
much because i don't want to lose you
guys
so when you breathe with your upper
chest when your mouth breathing
all the blood lives in the bottom of
your lungs you guys like that's where
the blood and all the good stuff lives
that it helps get the oxygen to your
cells
so when you're chest breathing so with
your mouth
you're not getting all of that
absorption in the bottom part of the
lobes so
that alone the biomechanics of that plus
you have
nasal nitric oxide so this is a gas that
your body produces which is a freaking
miracle molecule like look it up nasal
nitric oxide
it's just they call it no like the
generic term like viagra is made of
nitric oxide like that's how they
discovered that so it's
really great stuff for your blood you
know what i mean like it's good
and uh and it's produced on the exhale
through the nose
and if you slow down the breath and you
make your exhale longer
and then you inhale that air again man
you're getting all that nitric oxide
down
because it's a vasodilator so it really
helps oxygenate your blood
and uh understanding co2 tolerance
that's huge because that's going to help
the biomechanics of delivering oxygen to
the cells too
would it co2 tolerance sorry you're
using a lot i'm not a scientist i know
i'm trying
i'm gonna just i'm gonna just be real
with you a lot of times i don't know
what you're saying
i know i want an example but i don't
want people to be like what are you
talking about
no no um so what is co2 tolerance like
what does that mean
okay so carbon dioxide is what we
produce on the exhale
everybody thinks that they're they like
want to run away from co2 right they're
like oh this is bad we heard bad stuff
about it but
it's actually really good for the body
it's one of the
uh signals the signaling molecules to
help get oxygen to your blood
and get it out to your cells so
when you have to understand what a co2
tolerance is is a lot of us can't even
hold our breath for like three seconds
and when you've been mouth breathing you
are going to have a very low
co2 tolerance which means it's going to
be really hard for you to slow down the
breath
and get that exhale longer so that you
can produce more nitric oxide so that
you can reabsorb it in the lungs
so you want to be tolerant to it so that
you can actually slow your breath so
it's slow and silent
okay um so what
so you would say like step one is the
like that's actually where i'm at so
step one is the lip taping that's like
the first thing you do
once you've done that step two you're
gonna do breath work could you go into
like more detail like what type of
breath work you'd recommend
um because you know not everyone is able
to go to like a specialist
so this is why i think it's really
important for to like
tell people that one there's another
option instead of like
uh well one that this could be causing a
lot of like symptoms you have like one
thing i realized it probably caused my
tmj
oh yeah like with my mouth open all
these years like
that and that's what was bothering me
was i could never figure out like i was
kind of like you where i was like this
is like what caused this and i would go
to all these specialists
like did you get into a car accident i'm
like no like did this did this
and i was like no none of these things
happen but when i found your channel
it like clicked you know um sorry i
forgot i forgot what question i asked oh
yeah so what
what would you recommend to do like for
step two
okay so step two it honestly bouteco
it's b it's like bootyco b-u-t-e-y-k-o
and it's understanding like there's
different things you can do like they
have
free stuff on boutecoclinic.com and they
will tell you
about why the mouth breathing thing
happened and they will tell you how to
get rid of the snot they will tell you
how to slow down the breathing like they
have all these really cool
like things like there's this one where
you inhale and exhale
but only about 50 of your lung capacity
through your nose
and then it'll have you pause and then
it'll have you
breathe normal and then it'll ask you to
pause again so you're basically it's
like a workout you know like reps for
your lungs
and nose it's freaking awesome but
buteyko i like boutego i did try wim hof
if you guys have heard that uh but
that's a lot of oral breathing
and it's almost like supervised
hyperventilation and
i didn't like it i'd rather stick with
the nose because i know what it's doing
up here
and how long does someone have to do
that before they start to like feel
results or see results a little bit and
does that help you
because the biggest challenge i've had
the last couple weeks is like
remembering to close my mouth during the
day
so do you naturally start to do that
once you do the buteyko breathing
that helps but it's honestly becoming
obsessed with it um
it took me three months of thinking
about my tongue and lips from the minute
i woke up to the minute and i went to
bed
but it's all about neuroplasticity and
creating new neural pathways which is
neurology talk but there one really cool
thing i've learned with my patients
is you know the game jenga okay
so you don't necessarily have to talk
your way through the game of jenga
so especially with kids and grown-ups i
mean we're all the same we're just
different sizes
you play the game and the only rule is
your tongue must stay up on the roof of
your mouth your teeth must stay closed
lightly and your lips must stay closed
the entire game
because what will happen is if you are a
mouth breather and you have that
habitual
mouth drop it's going to be when you're
focusing on something you're like
you know yeah as soon as you focus on
something that bad boy pops open
so i it's just these little tiny
activities that you can do
every day other than you know being
obsessed with it which i hate
that you have to be but you do because
you have to rewire the brain
mm-hmm so but it happened like a habit
so so step two you would say um
so first the tape step two the exercises
then what's next uh myofunctional
therapy
you're like no yeah
that's what you that's what you do right
myofunctional therapy
uh we have it in my practice um so
you have to think about it this way your
tongue has eight separate muscles inside
of it right
and if it's laying on the bottom of your
mouth then you're not really chewing
hard foods because that's you know huge
part of it is like we're just eating
soft [ __ ]
yeah sorry can i cuss no
that's the stuff i react to in my
channel they cuss all the time okay okay
so
i'm such a rebel but myofunctional
therapy basically it takes all of your
floppy muscles that haven't been used
right and makes them strong so they work
better
to grow your face and just you know for
better control bigger airway while you
sleep like
you have to understand that even the
tongue has fat cells in it
so if you have a really crappy diet and
you have a lot of inflammation
your tongue actually gets bigger so not
only do you have a small box
you know like say you had crooked teeth
at some point
and your tongue literally doesn't fit on
the roof of your mouth but you have a
fat floppy tongue so myofunctional
therapy helps you
learn how to swallow properly because
this is something you do a lot
during the day if you're doing it wrong
you're making all the muscles just
dis-coordinated um working in
non-harmony basically so yeah it's
myofunctional therapy which is basically
toning the muscles and improving
function of the tongue and the face
what's an example of that like how um
because i'm imagining like the breath
work is like
you know like breathing in breathing out
slowly and controlled
um so my functional therapy what could i
have an
oh it's that i've seen that on your
channel
oh that's a version
this is virgin oh so it's just like
practicing
chewing mm-hmm oh my gosh i have tmj
that makes me like
yeah i know and and you understand that
your tongue
is your sling for your joint so if your
tongue gets stronger
then the joint takes less stress ie
hurts less
less fluid less inflammation well and
it's interesting because i went to so
many tmj doctors and nobody suggested
this
i know i know and that's why i had to go
past
my profession and just hit public
because it's coming out way too slow
yeah yeah yeah and then i also realized
like um
like back pain was probably like
attached to it because like you're
leaning forward in the air
yes so you're leaning forward you're
probably sleeping on a mountain of
pillows because your tongue keeps going
every night
um you have a very weak tongue which in
my opinion it the stronger your tongue
gets the better your posture is
because like it literally helps support
your head it's crazy
well and the other thing do you know
okay did you have i
i'm jumping a little bit because i'm
just excited to talk to you
or someone about this um do you did you
have when i started closing my mouth
because the two places i've been really
focusing on closing my mouth is when i
run and when i sleep and i actually
found that
i was shocked because my cardio got like
it was harder to
keep my mouth closed but when i did my
pace was actually
faster yeah you much faster yourselves
you get higher endurance rates like if
you go to
the oxygen advantage website like you're
working with like navy seals and
olympians like all of them
are talking about how important it is to
breathe through the nose
during high and dirt stuff like it's
crazy
is pretty mind-blowing i still can't do
it during a sprint
like i'm not there yet i can't i can't
um
i start but like during a run my pace is
way faster which is nuts
um okay but step three is the
my what was it called again them well it
goes by several names if you guys google
it it's omt which is oral facial
myofunctional therapy
it can be called just myofunctional
therapy
it can be like omt
that is what i would search okay and
then
what so is that the step you're on now
because i see you doing those exercises
or would you say you're like kind of
past
that into the next is there another step
there is no i mean it's just like every
day i have to make up for 37 years of
dysfunction
37 years of breathing stronghold with a
floppy tongue
and uh no every day i work on it i tape
my lips every night
i work out every morning every night on
my tongue and my facial muscles
i eat an anti-inflammatory you know
anti-inflammatory
diet because i i know that i have a
limited amount of space in here because
of the bone
and but as i grow the bone i still need
to make the most of the space so i try
to reduce
stuff that causes swelling in the whole
body okay so i guess four would kind of
be diet
right yeah yeah so yeah you're going to
get rid of the boogers and you want to
get really swelling
so and then it makes it because you eat
kind of a crazy like diet
that i like i've never seen
like i opened my eating window with um
clams oysters
sauerkraut and an avocado and then my
dessert is walnuts almonds
um chai seeds and blueberries with
uh hemp milk
i'm all right look i'm not gonna lie to
you this does not sound good
like i'm not i'm not gonna
i'm gonna backtrack a little bit okay
okay none of the changes
that i made would have been possible if
i did not take my lips and i'm gonna
tell you why
okay every night you actually get
restorative reparative sleep and you're
not
trying to breathe all night your brain
works better
dude like all of this like i call it my
airway journey but really it's a brain
journey
because when you finally start getting
the sleep the quality sleep that you
should have been having all these years
you are able to stick to things like
you're able to break bad habits you're
able to do things because they're good
for you like i
eat for the nutrients now and like it's
just as much about structure as it about
you know the function like my my brain
works better
it took two years honestly of lip taping
for me to
implement the food part but i did it and
my brain started functioning better so i
could do all this stuff and
you're saying you were able to change
your diet because you
taped your lips because as someone
that's
addicted to sugar i'm gonna be honest oh
yeah i
i can't imagine taping my lips
would improve a diet that i've been
trying to change for 24 years i like i
can't
i'm telling you you got to figure out
why you need the sugar why do you need
the caffeine
it's because synthetic energy dude you
guys
it's synthetic energy if you start
breathing better while you sleep
and your body can actually go to sleep
and fix broken parts
and work on you know clearing the brain
and make it work better short-term
memory all this stuff dude it's all
connected
um yeah you don't crave the sugar
anymore it's crazy really so were you
were you would you say you were addicted
to sugar before yeah but i had
yeah i would get the starbucks coffee i
would um love starbucks
donuts and anything that was a carb i'd
eat it
okay you're like so
oh my gosh that's so interesting because
i have always like i have a sister right
and i'm pretty sure she breathes out of
her nose
and she's always just like ate less than
me like always like
never like needed sugar like i do does
that make sense
and i've i'm like yeah like why
i crave it so much more than seemingly
other people even though we have these
same
genetics yeah what you're saying like
makes perfect sense
she's getting more oxygen to her brain
so she
doesn't need the sugar so it's actually
like that's another symptom of
yeah yeah i drive past those little
coffee stands like every two miles
i'm like this is an epidemic you guys i
go into the gas station and there's like
two coolers full of energy drinks like
this is an epidemic you guys
like nobody's looking at the breath like
if you look at the hierarchy like the
food chain of like things we need to
live
yeah first and if you're doing it wrong
you're gonna have some serious
consequences and it may not be blatant
obvious
and it may not happen overnight but it
will happen can you talk about some
other symptoms that people might not
like
typically think is because of their
breath but that you typically like see
you mentioned teeth grinding you meant
to
mention sugar addiction um we talked
about tmj and back pain what else
is there oh you know just i had hair
loss
like okay so because i wasn't getting
restorative sleep
you know i was choking on my body parts
every night um
my hormone dysregulation like my thyroid
was all jacked up like all of these
things
are supposed to happen like your body is
pretty fine-tuned you guys like it knows
how to fix itself you just gotta give it
the right information
and so when i wasn't getting to stay in
rem sleep which is like the
the money spot you know deep and rem
like if you can get
90 minute cycles of all those dude you
feel
amazing but yeah like i wasn't
regulating like half of my body parts
were just misfiring like
okay i'm gonna go really gross here you
guys hang tight so
my husband would always get up in the
morning and poop okay and i was like
that is so weird like he is so weird
like is that a guy thing like do you
guys just get every morning and poop
like
i only poop like maybe after a meal or
sometime
yeah and uh you know the more i looked
at like how it's all connected like
chinese medicine
ayurvedic like our body we have all the
information like
literally at our fingertips we just
don't know where to look and
yeah so when i i worked on like minerals
and
like all the things that would help my
sleep like i started pooping every
morning and i didn't get up to pee at
night like it's all connected
oh no all of it you're just saying a lot
of things that apply to my life and i'm
like dang there's even more stuff that i
never
my fingernails like the lines on my
nails and they were curving at the ends
like
and a lot of people have spot like we
just have to look at our bodies
i do have spots dude i'm telling you i'm
telling you it's all connected
and that goes back to the whole thing
like um
finding the root cause like we are
really great at making excuses like i'm
tired because i have kids or a puppy or
i'm tired because i drink too much water
and i had to get up to p3 times like
why are you tired like you have the
chance
to look at that as like hmm let me dig
deeper
or you can be ignorant to it and just
like live
waking up tired every day and i'm sure a
lot of america
like well even me because i always felt
like with my diet especially like
i i really consider myself like a
motivated and disciplined person but i
could never figure out why in my diet
i was so unmotivated and it's so
undisciplined like i'd try to go paleo
or something for a couple months but
i've just never been able to really
stick to it and
like what you're saying like makes
actually perfect sense because even when
i think of like
my parents like my dad um he naturally
he always breathes out of his nose my
mom doesn't
and um like my
mom would always like to say like things
like he just doesn't understand what
it's like to be like addicted to food
because my dad's just one of those
people
that doesn't overeat doesn't over you
know what i mean he just eats what he
needs
and my mom is does that make sense and
no
and you can see it literally on people's
faces if they are
struggling to breathe every night you
can see it on our faces once you see it
you can't unsee it
that's like because you see everyone so
guys it's like
um a receded chin basically and a big
nose so if you see people that have like
a bump on their nose
that actually you can get you can get
rid of that somewhat right if you have a
bump
on your nose you have to think about how
it works so the roof of your mouth is
the scaffolding for your nose right
and so what happens is if the roof of
your mouth drops down because your
tongue's not there to hold it up
the skin literally pulls down like your
whole face kind of melts
and that's where the hump comes from
it's the cartilage that we all have you
can just see it because the skin's being
pulled down
did you have a bump before i don't think
so i just had a really wide
face yes your side profile is literally
like people pay for that look at look at
her
like and that's why a lot of the people
that are on my channel are men
and that's something that men really
want is they want that like strong
jawline like it's like 95 men on my
youtube channel
yeah and and you know you don't have to
live with a beard you guys like
i know it's camouflage but you could
live without a beard if you wanted to
like if you did look into my functional
therapy i'm telling you
it's like an inside out facelift yeah
yeah that's what that's i'm so excited i
like figured this out now
and it's so cool because like literally
if you fix all the broken parts you get
to actually see what your genetic
potential would have been you know
like had i not fixed the dysfunction my
face would have continued to melt
basically
and now i get to see what i was supposed
to look like in the first place
um okay what is there any other symptoms
that we haven't talked about that you
think
like would maybe point to someone that
like they're breathing out of their
mouth and not their nose yeah there's
150
medical conditions related to breathing
disorders
um the first three common ones are high
blood pressure
okay anxiety and type 2 diabetes
okay why do you find someone in your
life or you
are suffering with any one of those
diagnoses
check your breath because there's a
really good chance you're sighing a lot
all day
you're making a lot of noise when you
breathe through your mouth like
you have phlegm and you're coughing and
doing all this stuff why
why don't you think like more people
know about this do you think it's a lack
of information
because even when i think like when my
sister struggles with anxiety and she
definitely has the like the
hump nose and receded chin and nobody's
even brought that up as a possible
solution you know um and she like she
has like a lot of the symptoms that
we're talking about and no one's ever
brought that up so do you think it's
just like
not enough people know about this or
what do you think the issue is
i i think it's a combination of issues
like i think
option one is there's no you can't
really market this
it's all work you gotta do at home you
know between breath work and tape in
your lips i mean there's
there's really not a whole lot of money
and making your muscles stronger like i
can't go to the gym and work out i
literally can do it in my office
yeah so i think that's one component
it's not a money maker you know
medicine's about money now unfortunately
um i think a lot of it is doctors
are trained to treat diseases yes
they're not trained to prevent diseases
for the most part you know some
functional medicine doctors are really
into this and like that's kind of
you know those are my people um but yeah
and
and here's the other thing too like we
know what's causing
all of these cancers right we know
what's in the food and the fda still
clears it like
we have access you know it's up to us to
make our own choices but no one's
informing us of all the consequences
and um i think if you hear the patient
you lose the customer wow
wow that's that's actually a really good
point you can't you can't market this
like what
how much are you really gonna make on
the little
and it's and it's not a quick fix like
you gotta want it like i had to wanna
not
snore anymore i had to want to stop
grinding like i had to want to
straighten my back out and
get my face to grow i had to want it and
a lot of people want the pill so that's
cool they're always going to be a market
for them
but if you're tired of waking up tired
you got to figure it out like is there a
chance your breathing
is a part of it and what is it that you
can do to fix your breathing
so what how long um you said to see
results it takes about
what do we say um a month or well maybe
even like you said a week for the lip
taping you'll start to feel a difference
which i
actually i actually noticed it the first
night i felt so much better on the
nights like i taped my lips
and you said three months for the
a lot of the words yeah myofunctional
therapy like three months
for you to get tolerant to co2 okay and
then you know
in conjunction start working on making
your muscles stronger
um but honestly the first year sucked
and you know because me i'm like the
olympian
of yeah you know and so it took me
i i mean it was a whole year of trial
and error like i
started tracking my sleep with this app
called snore lab
and then i was working on different body
positions or eating at different times
or
you know like i was like my own lap rab
or a lab rat whatever
and uh so yeah the first year was really
tricky but i kind of i wanted to learn
all of it so that i could say yay or nay
for those i wanted to kind of follow my
lead um
so you would say it takes about like a
year to see i'm just curious about like
the improvements in your like
overall health and your face how like
when did you start to notice like this
is a drastic
improvement rather than that like oh
there's just some improvements
yeah it didn't really like the first two
years all i did was lip tape
and slow down my and i worked a little
bit on the muscles but not a ton
but as soon as i was like okay this is
stupid why am i dragging my feet let me
just go all in
and i fixed the food like i went totally
anti-inflammatory diet i went to the
you know bone broth and my magnesium
and vitamin d and a and k2 like i went
hard on the nutrition part i was like
dude if i'm doing this much on the food
i might as well do this much on the
muscles yeah and within six months
i mean there were some significant
changes to my jawline
wow so you're saying like if someone
really dedicated themselves with like
food and like doing all the things that
you're talking about they could see
improvements in six months
oh totally yeah but the problem is most
people don't want to put in that work
they want to kill yeah yeah
wow this is actually really interesting
because i'm kind of like in the
beginning stages so i can kind of
gauge like what i need to put into it to
really get the results that i like want
yeah dude i'm telling you so last
weekend i was in florida for a company
retreat
and i broke all my own rules right so i
didn't do my stretches before bed
i did a little bit of breath work and i
took my magnesium but i drank alcohol
i went to bed past my normal bedtime
like i didn't take a shower i didn't
clear my nose like all these things that
i've
i do at home and i snored even with my
lips tape so
yeah okay so if you're looking at the
signs in the mouth
i mean we can see it so a scalloped
tongue
is basically your tongue trying to get
out of your air hole while you sleep
and all it is is dents on your tongue
from your teeth
like you go down you're laying down in a
supine position and your tongue is
choking you your body doesn't
care about your tongue or teeth so
literally when you open your mouth but
you keep your tongue in
you'll see little dimples around the
sides might be faint and it might go
away pretty quick but if you look at it
in the morning you can see them
not everybody is the same that's why
this thing is so tricky yeah
like dude their face looks freaking
awesome they have like all 32 teeth and
they still have a breathing problem
so it's that's i think that might be
another reason why it's so hard and
that's why nobody's
tackling it um front teeth if your front
teeth are getting flat dude
airway uh recession
so you're starting to see you know like
the gums around the front of your teeth
get like really receded like you can
almost see do you have it
i don't know i can't tell
it's so bad but you're still really
young i'm pretty early 20.
yeah a lot of this shows up like 30 um
just because your body's like dude i'm
out
i give up i can't keep keeping up with
you choking every night
uh so receding gums crack teeth decay
you know cavities dude or dirty teeth
say you go get your teeth cleaned every
three months and you still have
active gum disease so like dude look at
your mouth breathing there's a good
chance that's causing it
it's like crazy because all the bacteria
going crazy because it's all dry
right and there's no good guys in there
with a spit it's just like there's
a dehydration you know like there's a 40
greater water loss when you mouth
breathe versus nose breathing so
everybody's like
i don't know why my doctor keeps telling
me to drink water i'm like dude just
because you're letting it all out
because you're breathing through the
wrong hole
wow so when people are dehydrated that
could be caused from mouth breathing too
because there's other modalities of
treatment um
i could have easily gone into an oral
growth appliance
which is made by an airway focused
dentist
and it is designed to move the palatal
bones
so that you have more air space in your
nose okay
right i could have gone that way but i
didn't want to because
i knew the majority of people a barely
believed me
that this is an issue like how even
matters b
aren't about to spend you know six
thousand dollars
um and i'm like well there's got to be a
natural way like if this happened to me
because of nature and i can fix it
why wouldn't i be able to correct it
like
we are not made of stone you guys we're
practically made of rubber
and your face is gonna change shape no
matter what you do
it can be for the better or for the
worse you get to pick
because muscles dictate bone and i
wanted to show that it could be done
okay
why are this is actually a question i
have why are some people just like
get like i was wondering why my sister
like was just gifted with this natural
ability to breathe out of her nose
and some people aren't like we have the
same exact genetics
but she you don't you know what i'm
saying like do you know why that is
yeah okay so it literally like they're
they're anthropologists out there and
they're like dude it could have been a
bad cold when you were an infant
like it could have triggered mouth
breathing for the rest of your life and
if no one was there to be like oh hey by
the way you're breathing through the
wrong hole some bad shit's gonna go
happen down
like down the line um yeah so
it could be as simple as a cold it could
be as simple as
you ate something that you had a food
sensitivity to and then you got
inflammation and you've got congestion
and you started not breathing it could
be a tongue tie you know those are real
like
literally if your tongue is stuck to the
floor of your mouth it can't sit up
there and grow your face
there's all kinds of reasons like it
could even be like i got punched you
know like and broke my nose three times
like and then i started mouth breathing
but the problem with it mouth breathing
is it's this vicious circle dude
if you start breathing through your
mouth like you get more snot
because your body doesn't know that
you're breathing through the wrong hole
it just thinks you're hyperventilating
so it starts laying down more mucus
what about like um tonsils being removed
is that of anything
to because i did have my tonsils removed
as a baby
they were just like taking everybody's
back then that's what my mom said like
mine
and it helped for like six months um and
then i went right
back to you know all the snot um yeah so
if you think about why your tonsils and
adenoids are inflamed
most of the ents will tell you a it's
always the food
you're eating [ __ ] food that causes
inflammation of mucus
you're skipping the filters in the nose
so there's cilia so the nose goes
or the air goes in your nose right you
got these little hairs with snot on them
that traps the big particles of bacteria
and viruses and whatnot
then you have these chambers all
throughout your face dude
it's gonna make that air warm and moist
and filter out more stuff you know so
it's totally ready for your lungs and
just in case something gets missed on
the way down
your adenoids and tonsil tissue grabs
the rest of it
that way the air is totally ready for
you right your lungs i mean it's like
primed it's like chewing your food
before you swallow
and what happens is if you're breathing
with your mouth
you skip all the filters and all of that
unfiltered air it goes straight back to
the last filter and it's just not
equipped to handle it so it gets all
pissed off and
swollen and and the last filter would be
like your tonsils and your add noise
yeah
yeah and so oh my gosh so last but mouth
breathers make it the first
i don't even have that so that makes it
worse right
yeah you have less filters but you know
they can't remove all the tissue
i mean okay they're still yeah like they
they just can't because it's attached to
your body so they usually do like an
ectomy where they take out some of the
adenoid tissue some of the tonsil tissue
like the oral tonsils they can take out
those are the ones that are right behind
your soft palate in your mouth
but the adenoid tissue i mean there's
still some there and and that's the
whole thing
they get full circle back to root cause
like we don't have extra body parts like
i shouldn't have had eight teeth pulled
i shouldn't have had my tonsils and
adenoids cut out
i shouldn't have had ear tubes like no
one looked at why
it happened right well they probably
didn't know back then right
no dude okay so james nestor he's
brilliant right he wrote this book
called
breath the new science of a lost art
and rogan right
oh my gosh he's amazing but but he made
it so easy for like layman people like
non-industry people
to get it like we've been talking about
breath like yogi's and
and all this stuff like your tongue
should be up for the closing of the
circle of chi
like it's been in chinese medicine but
for some reason it keeps getting lost
i don't i can't figure that out and
that's why meditation like works right
because they're like focusing on their
because i always thought people were
kind of crazy and they're like
meditating i'm like
i'm not going to be like
it is breath work i mean like the more
breath work i did i'm like damn i'm a
meditator
i i do i'm just sick of not being able
to breathe like i i haven't been able to
breathe like ever
and i thought the um i was really
disappointed because
when i got the surgery it didn't fix it
and i thought it would
i know yeah it's a functioning behavior
i mean that's what it's
down to like if you don't fix the way
you breathe at night
or during the day you won't fix it at
night and i mean i had so many patients
that
were kind of like you that thought you
know
i did what i was told and it didn't fix
like right now we're at
when a kid gets their tonsils and
adenoids removed if in three months
their body doesn't autopilot back to
breathing through their nose
then we're allowed to go in and be like
you need breath work you need
myofunction but right now we have to
still
you know recommended wait three months
to see if their brain will reprogram to
put them
breathing through the right hole on
their own
now that the obstructions move but a lot
like me you know i had my tonsils and
now noise taken out
and still mouth breathing
um i think that if i was
to emphasize anything on
you really want to grow your face um
you have to learn about it because
you won't care that much to try and fix
it with the effort that it takes to grow
your face
until you understand how it's related to
so many comorbidities
the minute you realize holy [ __ ] this is
because of chronic over breathing oh
because i was breathing through my mouth
oh i didn't have nasal nitric oxide oh
my co2 tolerance is low oh
i wasn't moving my diaphragm so i'm
literally like
my intestines were never getting
massaged like my back was trying to
support all of the stuff like it's all
connected yeah you won't really i mean
if you really want
to change it what we understand is
nothing changes if nothing changes
if you don't tape your lips if you don't
slow your breath
if you don't eat the food that makes
your bones grow like precursors to
uh collagen you have to understand that
stuff if you don't
stretch your body move the fluid move
the fascia like
if you don't focus on sleep hygiene go
to bed same time
take a shower blow your nose like if you
don't do these things
you won't see change but you won't know
how to do them until you learn about
them
so i that's what i i mean when i'm on
takedown exactly what i'm trying to do
is like dude
like you have got to learn about it
otherwise it doesn't seem important
because you're still living
you're like dude i breathe through my
mouth every now and then i
you know let me a couple times a day and
clear my throat like
what's the big deal but if you don't
understand how
there's no such thing as healthy mouth
breathing
then you won't be able to accomplish
anything i mean
awareness is one step but taking action
is putting that tape on your lips and
bringing through your nose so your brain
works better
so now that you're on the other side can
you talk about like you're a day in your
life
before and a day in your life like now
like tell
tell me why like why should i go through
all of this like what's on the other
side of all this like work
dude i'm 41 i feel like i found the
fountain of freaking
youth i have never had this much energy
my brain has never
worked this well nothing hurts i don't
have to take advil tylenol any nsaids
anymore um
no more migraines like that alone shoot
if if anything
if only one thing came out of my journey
and the migraines were gone
that's worth it the other stuff is
literally just icing on the cake
those headaches are debilitating and
there's quality life sucks and i would
never go back there
and you know what i also noticed about
you like your skin looks perfect
like like this is this is a replacement
to botox
like genuinely when i was growing up
everybody's like don't touch your face
you'll get wrinkles don't touch your
face you'll get pimples
like oh my god i've never touched my
face this much in my entire life
i literally i'm petting myself all the
time
and what i'm doing is i'm stimulating
the drainage of lymphatic fluid
and i am bringing blood flow to the
surface of the skin
could you show me all your like a little
appliances you have
do you have them in front of you i have
yeah i brought them for you yeah
can you show them on the channel tell me
like what each tell me what each thing
does
like how does it help you okay so i
can't find my
um stone but this is a jade roller and
it since i do work out my muscles a lot
i like to move around the lactic acid
that builds up
and so basically it just helps drain the
fluid out of the face
and helps you know move blood flow so
that the muscles recover
um this is a button pull and this is
going to strengthen the front of my face
because what we understand about
forward facial growth is the lips play a
huge part of that
so the button pull i'm
activating the obicularis muscle which
is like the sphincter muscle around your
face but it's different
for your lips because it's actually
connected to all these other muscles
so when i pull against this resistance
training
i'm strengthening and like bringing my
like just think about it like i'm trying
to pull my face forward so it's
literally
helping me do that um this is called
jewelry and i have asymmetry which a lot
of amount breather people
we do one side of our face is
undeveloped compared to the other
okay well my underdeveloped side was my
left side
you could see like my eye was lower um
and my teeth when i smile you can see
the gum line is lower
than my right side like there's mine's
like that because my right side's lower
like this side is like kind of right
i it's hard to tell but i mean if i was
in front of you i could be like yeah
and a lot of us like my crooked teeth
that even after braces
was on my left side like it rebound um
that was like my underdeveloped side and
my
you know i have less mobility my left
arm oh my gosh that's my that's the same
side that
it's like i don't have that crooked
teeth but like a little bit on the bot
oh my gosh
well that's what i'm saying like i could
look at somebody and be like dude your
face looks awesome but they still have
breathing problems so that's where
like this happened when i was a kid so
you could see it in my face
but now though your face is like very
symmetrical
it's getting there yeah it's crazy
because like there's a couple indicators
that you know you're on the right path
especially if you're not being
supervised by an airway focused provider
when i swallow pills like i don't hit my
soft palate anymore so i know that i'm
getting
like expansion that way um the i can
when i'm doing my eyebrows like i used
to have to like
compensate big time like i'm like how do
i make this look like a brow
like the hair over here even over there
but as your face starts to gain symmetry
like all of your body parts become
symmetrical
and and that's what they're talking
about like there are no genes for
asymmetry there are only genes that you
turn on in the human body for symmetry
like we're supposed to be balanced you
know our hearts on one side our lungs on
the other
or livers on the other but as far as
like the
cranial facial respiratory complex we're
supposed to have symmetry
well it's just crazy because you see all
these like
botox and all these like cosmetic
procedures and that they could just fix
it through this one thing
i'm telling you but that's what it comes
back to like do you want to take the
pill or do you want to do the work
and look at your insecurities if you
think your lips are small
wonder why if you think you're you know
your eye is droopy wonder why
like it's just connecting the dots like
we have all these band-aids on bullet
wounds and yes you may look different
but you haven't fixed the problem
and then you won't feel great you'll
just look different and then
wow this is this is blowing my mind
because i just
i like know all the stuff that i've
considered like cosmetically i've never
really done anything other than the nose
but like
stuff i've like considered cosmetically
that like
wow you don't even have do you see all
over tick tock these girls doing these
before and out you know what i mean and
they don't have to do any of it wow is
there any other like appliances or those
the three you have
um i use um
like a stainless steel
stone well it's not a stone because it's
stainless steel but it's like one of
those flat ones i don't know where it is
oh oh yeah it's like a gua sha
okay i use that on my neck so
between c1 and c7 a lot of our mouth
breathers
uh we've always had this forward head
posture because our tongue isn't
you know and um and i've been using that
like
i come you know from the cranium and i
just kind of pull down
that has been a huge helper trying to
you know fix my forward head posture
um yeah a lot of it's like
just tongue exercises like putting your
tongue in your cheek this one's called
the jawbreaker
so
and you want everything to be as still
as a statue because you're trying to
work out your tongue
oh all right
sorry yeah if you get five there's like
um the cave
which is really standard it's just where
you suction your tongue to the roof of
your mouth and you hold really still
wait wait oh my gosh that's harder than
it looks
if you have a trouble like trying to
find that suction just do the click
sound like
remember what it takes to make the click
and it's that feeling
before you pop down
oh so that's like where your tongue is
supposed to be that's where it's
supposed to be that's what it's supposed
to be doing that's further back than i
thought actually
the whole thing should be flat yeah it
holds the
soft palate like that's why the tongue's
so cool it's like a body part that
literally holds up another body part
while you sleep
and if that body parts drop down then
the soft palate
dangles and that's when you get the
snore and stuff collapses
wow this you're like making so much
stuff make sense
well that's my my job like literally
like they in order to become
a true expert you have to be able to
explain the complex simply
and it took me so long to get here
because
i was looking at it from a structural
problem when it was actually
behavior and function can you heal tmj
through this stuff do you think yeah
yeah i mean unless the discs are super
degenerated like and they've been
popping out of socket and you've lost
like
actual parts of the disc that
fly in and out yeah i mean a lot of
people and most of the tmj
pain is actually in the muscles like
people actually have pain in the joint
itself yeah i actually
um i don't even tell the pain it's just
annoying like i just so loud
and like yeah and then you have to worry
about it
staying open locking open but you have
to understand that that's why i do the
omt the myofunctional therapy it
strengthens the muscles of the face
yeah that takes the burden off of this
bad boy so he stops popping he stops
hyper
extending like you get the tongue and
you get the face stronger
and the joint's supported the way it's
supposed to be well
i'm the thing i would say is don't
settle you know there's so many people
that
and i i say this a lot they become their
diagnosis
i have anxiety i have depression i have
diabetes type two
i have high blood pressure like stop
identifying with the condition
that's caused by the modern world we
live in
you know stop identifying with that like
say i used to
like i think the mentality part of it
like
the the better sleep i get every night
the better my brain works the better my
body works
like i'm almost becoming i don't want to
say spiritual but like i get it like
you know i before i didn't care about
the environment like i just throw
plastic away but now i want to recycle
like there's all these weird things like
it's all connected
but i think that's what happens with
when you get better oxygen while you
sleep
and you just your your personality kind
of changes and it's
it's a little intimidating like i'm not
who i was and it's good but it's
different
like every reality changes a little bit
yeah like
i just see things differently um and my
family is having a hard time with that
i'm like they're like why do you put
your water in a green jar on the porch
i'm like well i really want the
photosynthesis like
and just like just little things and
they're like why are you over there
breathing and like why are you laying on
the ground like
they're looking at me funny like i'm a
whack-a-doodle now i'm like you don't
get it like it's these little things
every little thing adds up
yeah and every choice i make during the
day is
is trying to positively impact my sleep
that night like
i think ahead every day like what can i
do today what
can i do some yoga can i do a sauna can
i do a cold shower like can i
eat foods that are like
anti-inflammatory like how many
blueberries can i eat today like i get
super excited and everybody's like i
don't get it i'm like you don't get it
because
you're not getting that oxygen to your
brain every night like i am now
well they say it's like a ship right
like um
if you have two ships right here and
they start in the same spot if one
person just makes like a small
change in ten years they're in a
completely different place than someone
who didn't make that change and i'm 24
so
um i've been out of the house since i
was 18 and i'm just starting to like
realize how much like my like choices
and my
because before i wasn't my nothing
really was my choice it's your parents
oh yeah but i think like your mid-20s
you start to realize like
how in control like your life is you do
you know what i'm saying like yeah ever
there's so many of us that you know give
our power away
you know like and i think western
medicine kind of did that to us too
you know they've like brainwashed you
like you have to do this you have to do
that
um i i think there's alternate ways of
looking at everything like
whether choices that you make in your
job what you do with your life like what
you eat
how you treat central headquarters
that's what yeah
headquarters what you put in here
matters everywhere
and you know is if you're growing your
face i picked the foods that i have to
chew like there's almonds and walnuts in
there and
are they easy to chew no are they going
to give me a workout while i eat yes
are they good for my body oh my goodness
they are like it's all related
that's interesting so it's actually
helpful to like
oh i didn't even think of that like
that's why your diet is so weird no
offense but
yeah i want stuff i have to chew because
then it's less work out with us other
stuff
wow but the hardest part honestly like
if you do jump on the airway train and
you guys start taping your lips and
maybe you look into boutique oh and you
start doing some breath work
and then maybe you like say oh that
sugar that
dairy that gluten maybe that's really
causing me a lot of snot so let's ditch
it for a little bit like people are
gonna look at you weird like
why do you care which hole i breathe
with like it doesn't matter
oh you're breathing knitting i was gonna
ask in terms of diet what foods do you
avoid that was actually one thing i
wanted to jump into that we
didn't actually get to so uh
i try to avoid anything with refined
white sugar
that causes a lot of snot you know
because if you're trying to be a
recovering
mouth you know breather like you don't
want any extra snot like you're going to
go out of your way
to not eat foods it's going to cause
mucus because you already have a limited
amount of space
what is refined white sugar like how
would i know because
i'm not like an expert by any means so
it'll go into
if it's not um like cane sugar it'll say
just sugar
or it'll be sucralose or fructose or
next roast like anything that ends with
an oats
not so good it'll just say sugar on it
yeah
yeah if it doesn't say cane sugar um
like and the oasis i mean they're really
trying to like pull the wool over our
heads there with that one
um seed oils and vegetable oils no go
yeah they cause a lot of olive oil no
olive oil is good
avocado oil is good coconut oil is good
i really wouldn't eat anything outside
of those three oils
okay so definitely no vegetable oil for
this chick
like it cost what about gluten are you
anti-gluten
anti-dairy no i mean dairy was causing
me some snot but i don't think it's the
dairy like the more research i do it's
the way we're taking the milk from the
cow
you know we're getting a lot of steroids
and you know like it's just
there's a lot of stuff wrong with the
way we milk the cows now compared to
like what we did so i don't think it's
actually the milk i think it's the
process that's kind of like taking all
the good
parts of milk out and causing snot okay
but so do you i don't drink milk no not
anymore
no i mean like they find like some dairy
that does it like old
no i mean school you in general
recommend people don't eat like so if
i'm like
i'm at the point where i'm trying to
like take this mouth journey like i've
been taping my lips for a little bit i
really want to take it to the next level
um i'm just curious like so outside of
the refined sugars
what is there like a a type of diet you
recommend like paleo gluten free you
know i'm saying like there's so many
different types of diets
but if you're not that's what you gotta
like that's the thing
it's not a diet you have to eat for the
nutrients
if you want to grow your face you need
your nutrients right
you need omega-3s you need healthy fats
you need probiotics so that your gut
bugs can get the good stuff in your
bloodstream you know
you have to think about it differently
like it's not about what i can't have
it's what i get to eat that's going to
help me grow my face while i sleep
tonight
okay like these blueberries dude if if
you did nothing to change your diet
a cup of blueberries a day i mean
honestly like
it's anti-inflammatory it helps with
circulation
brain health heart health like dude this
one blueberry
is a freaking miracle piece of fruit
it's crazy
it's blueberry
um yeah just it's it's understanding you
know
if you could skip gluten that's cool if
you could skip
refined dairy that's cool if you could
skip the white sugars
very cool like those are going to help
you get a lot less snot real quick
okay and then understanding gut health
like what am i missing like
that's when you look at the minerals you
know the magnesiums they're a big deal
vitamin b's big deal vitamin e
big deal k2 vitamin a like
i just and it's one of those things that
i didn't just jump in overnight and
understand like
which parts of foods i needed to grow my
bottom my body parts
but every night you get sleep and your
short-term memory improves like you're
you're able to start oh
that's what i really need like and i i
missed a ton of frogs dude to find my
prints because like
i started with some really off-the-wall
like holistic
supplements and i don't take those
anymore it's literally just like
my five staples which is magnesium d a
k and b
i don't even think of like um
your memory would improve because
this is what i'm saying i was actually
diagnosed with add or adhd but so is
everyone so i don't really
is that bad i don't take it seriously
because i i every other person i meet
has been diagnosed with that so i'm like
well a lot of
let's have all these other issues too
yeah yeah and i talked about it
i took the medication for like six
months right
but it was terrible i didn't sleep i
like
i was so anxious like i did i just
didn't like it so i just
i i tossed that like pretty quick does
that make sense like because i just
wasn't i didn't like it
and now i realized like there's a
holistic like solution
for like my bad memory too and that's
something i never would have
thought of and it's just crazy because i
look at like my sister
who breathes out of her nose and she
she's always had a really good memory
and all this stuff that we're talking
about like it's kind of like i was the
bad guinea pig she was like the good
guinea pig
you know what i mean and it's crazy like
i always think about like you know and
it's funny because this is really i
don't have enough research on it but
like smokers you know like
how do they smoke cigarettes like is it
because they're
they're okay with breathing through
their mouth like that's just not a big
deal for them to put smoke in the wrong
hole like if they're just used to
putting air in the wrong hole
and then like i look at all my like
super healthy friends they're like oh
smoking's disgusting like i wonder if
they think that
for the majority of that is because they
don't want to breathe with their mouth
because
it's wrong for them but for me like it
was easy to smoke a cigarette
because i was already brewing the other
hole anyways like i wonder how many
connections we still haven't made
wait you used to smoke you smoked
cigarettes before i didn't even know
that
i grew up in the 90s i mean everybody
was hip and smoking cigarettes yeah now
it's the
the e yeah no i was always i was drank
like that was my thing but like um
after college you kind of start to see
like the reap that's what i was talking
about you start to see the repercussions
of like the choices that you made so
i actually like stopped drinking like
that after college because i was like oh
my gosh
i feel terrible like four years and this
has been like so bad on my health
yeah and you know okay and you don't
care
yeah as you get older you compensate
less yeah and that's why all these
people hit 40 and something breaks
like oh [ __ ] this happened overnight i'm
like no it didn't it happened 20 years
ago when you were tearing this [ __ ] up
you just happened to be able to adapt to
it until now
yeah yeah and that's what that's what i
realized and i was like i can't even
blame anyone for this but me
like you don't even when you're in your
mid-20s you start to realize dude this
is no one's fault but my own
and you're lucky you're actually ahead
of the curve like half of my friends
didn't wake up till 35 or something
really they're still like partying and
stuff till like 35
oh my gosh no i did it in college and
then i was like this is terrible
i feel awful i want to go home like i
was out i was over it
i want to help i i want to make it easy
um i know it's not easy
and i think the fact that it's not a
quick fix a lot of people don't want to
do it
and if you don't want to do it you're
never going to believe that breathing
through your mouth causes problems
okay rhonda well thank you so much for
coming on the channel
i really appreciate it um is there any
final words you want to give to the
viewers just as advice
um as your last like thing you want to
say
ah yeah okay how you breathe matters you
guys
slow and silent through the nose at rest
your tongue should be suctioned to the
roof of your mouth with light suction
from the tip to the back
your teeth should be [ __ ] slightly
touching or
you know closed but not gaped far apart
and your lips
should be shut they should be closed
shut without effort
like that is physiological rest posture
of the craniofacial respiratory complex
like if you really want to
fix the problem you have to know where
your body parts are
and what they're doing well perfect
thank you
so much um i appreciate it um this was
my first interview so i was really
excited to do it with you
um and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys next time